Chúng ta mạnh quân ngày 1 tháng 2 cho biết Chiu Tien là đầu công 2 một loại tây lửa không đối đất tầm xa.
Trong lấy kiến nghiệm 8,5 thành lập được lượng không quan giễn ra tại sân bay khăn mà
hôm 2 ngày táng 3,5, các xe nửa đã đăng tại hình ngành các mấy bài chính đấu,
mang theo loại tây lửa mới có tí tế được đánh xá là tương tự dòng Charles
vô kí ăn trình phóng thời xin không của đất.
Đây là là đủ tiên bình dẫn dưới thiệu khi tài thủ loại này.
Chúng bài phát biểu tầm buổi lễ nhà lãnh đạo kiến trường như mạnh ký vọc
đối với lượng không quan lực lượng nắm giữ phát chào quan trảo trong năng lượng ra đe chính lượng của Chiu Tien
giờ qua xanh nhận định phát biểu ngành nhằm khẳng định ưu thay của loại tây lửa mới trong việc thống phòng thủ.
Tên là Charles của đất thuy điện của tâm bản khoảng 50% tươi mấy và đủ chính xa cao
khiến đường nhiều cua xa xử dụng, nếu phí bản Chiu Tien sẽ rữ thông số tương tự.
Hí tài này sẽ tạo thêm đăng kênh xu mạnh sản đe chương bình dẫn.